amazon has slashed the cost of its go
cashier-less store technology by 96
since 2017 this is an insider story let
me let me tell you what this means this
means
if the cost was a million dollars to run
this store
now it's only forty thousand dollars
that's what this means
it doesn't mean prices went down it
means the overhead of running this place
went from a million bucks to 40 grand so
amazon has
radically reduced the cost of its just
walk out cashier-less store technology a
testament to companies ability to turn
long-term experimental projects into
more affordable business offerings
amazon estimates the operating costs for
technology behind a thousand square foot
gold cashier less store has dropped a
hundred and fifty nine thousand dollars
a store this year that's a ninety six
point four percent decline from four
million a year and 2017.
a month before it opened the first
location even more savings are
forecasted by the end of 2023 the cost
includes payments for using amazon web
services cloud technology and hiring
remote employees who manually verify the
accuracy of checkouts and stores amongst
other tasks amazon debuted it's go cash
your list store in 2016 creating the
convenience store where customers could
purchase items through an app without
having to go through a checkout out so
the consequences of you sitting on the
sideline is companies who are innovative
who don't sit around say
i kind of got to figure this part out so
this is where this takes me this is
where it takes me takes me to a couple
different places i want to share my
thoughts on this and i want to hear your
thoughts and rebuttal on this this is
where this takes me number one
so
uh the first part is where you know the
whole orange stuff you know you know the
guy doesn't want to wear the vest yeah
that's probably one percent of the
population whatever that just 4.4
million i get that but the same way this
guy's talking about 10 of it is crypto
only america's investors are seven
percent as crypto community so out of
that seven percent of crypto community
what percentage that made a lot of money
maybe some of them got in late so that's
why two three percent that vest let's
just say one or two percent fine
here's the part i think about here's the
part i think about okay and this is
gonna come sound a little weird but what
the hell is the purpose of us being
alive and living like what are we
supposed to do are we just supposed to
sit around collect the check from the
government and play video games and
smoke weed are we just supposed to stay
home assume the government's gonna send
me a check and i'm gonna have kids with
my wife and we stay home and watch
netflix all day long while they pay me
five grand a month and that is my life
like do you really not think eventually
at some point when you're watching these
inspirational aspirational movies like
pursuit of happiness like gladiator like
you know any of these movies you can
lean on me you sit there and say what
the hell is my purpose is my purpose to
have somebody give me free money on a
monthly basis so it can steal my dreams
away or do i want to do something big
with my life so maybe my legacy is not
going to be worldwide like an elon musk
or a
president or a billionaire or an athlete
or a hollywood celebrity but maybe my
legacy is going to be regional maybe
it's going to be statewide maybe it's
going to be a local community i was a
star that came out of my city and i
started a business and we have 200
employees or maybe i'm just going to be
that cousin that did something special
on our family and i inspired my nephews
and niece to want to do something big as
well i'm proud of that it doesn't matter
what it is maybe you're the first kid
out of your family that got a degree
maybe you're the first kid out of your
family that became a doctor maybe you're
the first kid out of your family that
came out and started a business
raise healthy kids they did good they
became good citizens at the end of the
day this whole thing about ubi to me is
listen the technology innovative
creative people they're not going to
wait on you to complain
you can complain all you want they will
gradually sit there and say you know
what machines don't complain
they produce
and why am i not going to just keep
producing machines so then if i'm a 22
28 year old 32 year old person right now
sitting there listening to this i'm kind
of like
yesterday robert asked me a question
about what would you do in today's
economy i said everything i'm looking at
is finding a way to be irreplaceable
what is irreplaceable mean what can i do
to be irreplaceable what kind of value
do i bring to the marketplace what kind
of context do i bring to the marketplace
what skill sets do i need today that's
going to be valuable 18 months from now
36 months from now five years from now
am i a good leader am i good at working
with people am i good at solving issues
am i compatible do i get along with
people am i a good negotiator do i build
good leaders what is my value so if you
ain't thinking about producing your own
type of value today in the marketplace
you're probably going to be replaced by
a machine and a robot and this whole ubi
concept that people think it's a good
idea
all it's doing is stealing your purpose
away from life and what a waste of a
life ain't nobody want that and there's
no no there's no dignity there's no
integrity none there's no there's no you
have no values you can pass down to your
children why have kids why do we watch
inspirational movies though why do we
watch great movies what what happens at
the end of the movie when you and i
watch a movie that just what do you why
do you watch rocky you know for why do
you watch these movies you want to be
the underdog who comes back and wins
that's it that's like in our dna
is to be somebody we all want to be
somebody and this free money steals that
away from people i mean george
washington crossed look our founding
fathers are spinning in their graves
they fought for freedom they fought for
liberty they fought for a population
that could have a purpose
they've been
there have been countless american boys
who've paid with their lives and women
who've paid with their lives
for this
yeah i don't i don't know and
you know listen but here's here's the
part you know how they say uh uh the
more things change the more they don't
like everything
yeah the whole thing where it's like hey
well let me tell you this is the end of
the world now listen 50 years ago there
was free loaders 50 years ago there was
low income middle income 50 years ago
there was guys that capitalized 50 years
ago there was criminals 50 years ago
there was dividers 50 years ago there
was guys that wanted free money 50 years
ago they were communists 50 years ago
there were guys that hated rich people
50 years i mean it's this ain't changing
the only thing that's changing is the
following here's the only thing that's
changing today
50 years ago if my wife and i got into a
fight while i'm at work and have a 30
minute drive when i'm coming home
50 years ago i probably didn't have a
cell phone to call her and get into
biggest fight and say a word i regret
because ends up leading to our marriage
eventually leading into a divorce 50
years ago i had 30 minutes to calm down
by the time i came home and i'm like
listen i'm so sorry let's just figure
this out we're good okay we're good we
move on right
50 years ago
when hit the fan you didn't hear
about it until 14 hours later
50 years ago maybe you heard it at news
8 o'clock at night but maybe you didn't
hear about it on the paper the next day
it took a while so the reaction was we
were more calm when we reacted today's
like what happened let me post it oh my
gosh
so the exaggeration of issues today is
so much bigger that we are reacting and
it's making every good reaction yes
that's the only thing so that's the only
part that people have to be very careful
so quickly yeah i can't even process it
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye
[Music]